well we just had a very exciting Women's
World Championship and we have our
champion who was here in st. Louis a Jew
in June what a match that was though it
was a real thriller not only it was a
real thriller but I think that it really
showed like what characters these
players have because like games were so
long they like it showed that they are
ready to fight not only like so the last
pawn but I think it it showed that they
were preparing mentally for this event
for months and that they're so resistant
and resilience once again but also so
creative it's like I really enjoyed this
match and so I well I hope that Joe and
June will will continue like her win and
stroke I don't know if we were talking
about the current Scott predictions and
results but I think she's she deserves
her victory well yeah it was a great
match I mean just to recap it for a
little for a little bit 12 games
classical slow start a few draws we
started to worry maybe there's gonna be
a lot of draws in this match but then it
just blew wide open and we had actually
6 out of 12 decisis of games in the
classical portion I mean it was really a
roller coaster if you had a favorite in
this fight your heart was all Oh heart
was dropping on a daily basis in this
event as jewel in June and Gorge gonna
traded punches um were there any games
that stood out to you in this
championship match well especially from
the psychological point issue its when
garage key no one and she took the lead
in the match so I was actually wondering
myself like what is going through the
mind of the players how they do manage
you know like to prepare like are they
sleeping you know there's like million
of thoughts that are racing through your
head and how I think that we should
underline the specifics of chess it's
like normally in any other sports like
if you lose you're done but in chess not
only that you have to play after a
defeat so then you have to cope with
this you have to analyze your mistake
and then it's sort of resurrection you
have to play again and you have a chance
like to bounce back and to win the match
so for me as a player as a fighter that
was a really crucial moment and that's
where derringer and showed her character
but nonetheless kudos to Alexandra
garage can she showed that she put on a
great fight and she showed like she has
great potential like she's so young so
funny one yes she's 21 and I'm actually
looking forward to the next candidates
tournament because it will be really
interesting to know like who is going to
qualify in the Challenger jus in June
for the next time it will be very
fascinating and you know that final game
really captured my heart just on the
ropes white pieces
Alexander needed to win to force
tiebreaks otherwise she was out and Joe
and June would retain her title and she
played d4 d5 Knight c3 and that caused
the Chinese world champion to take a 20
minute thing which is crazy you know
you're like what is going on if you're
on her team right and in the end
Alexander did win that game we're seeing
this monumental playoff it reminds me
actually of poker players strategy
sometimes when you make a move and then
you have to extrapolate so it like does
he know that he knows like that or like
so that I know and then what am I
supposed to play so I think this 20
minutes thought was actually very
meaningful because she had to go through
all of the openings that her opponent
prepared so the QI prepared that to
avoid the line where they might be a lot
of traps so that happens but they think
that this match also show that this
during June started her games with b3
when she wanted to surprise her
opponents so not only they were prepared
technically but I think they dedicated a
lot of time to their mental and
psychological preparations
psychological preparation is so relevant
and
after the match I need security or after
that 12 game onigiri said that this is
one of the best World Championships he's
seen in terms of drama
so he's it wonderful to see the top
players in the world giving the respect
that the Women's World Championship
deserves and speaking of respect you
know money and respect do go hand in
hand and in this match the purse was
really sweet it was five hundred
thousand dollars or euros was he euros
or dollars I think it was I think you're
yeah five hundred thousand euro and that
was an incredible increase from previous
years of course but I think now we
should notice that that's the general
trends so prices and women's
competitions are getting higher and
especially here for example and Karen's
Cup yes I remember when I like we talked
about this last year when I won like my
first super tournament in Krishna
Turing's in 2004 like the first was
three thousand dollars the first the
first yes and this year they this year
the last place gets twice that all me
era exactly so I am actually so happy it
means that woman's just is more and more
recognized and there are a lot of
initiatives also to promote chess among
women and girls I know that there are a
lot of initiatives in the United States
and it pays off because they're the
women's team is getting stronger you
have so many young players which are
strong and one of them is playing in the
Karen's Cup that's right charissa yep
and she actually Chrissie gifted some
annotations of that match for chess life
online at u.s. chess and she is a
phenomenally talented writer which
sixteen she's already an I am and she's
also a great writer so Carissa just a
super talent but one thing that struck
me about this match going back to the
match was the end game play the champion
really outclassed in the end game and it
seemed like the game wins that Alexander
put on we're more like just you know
brutal victorious but it's actually
strange because it seemed to be
Alexandra's like a strongest point the
end game
and as we saw during June managed to
I'll play her like on on her battlefield
so it's well once again it shows that we
have such a deserving champion I think
that one of her strongest qualities is
the middle game she likes the dynamic
she but on the other hand she like
mustard so well the opening and the end
game so it's a really instructive games
there like her first victory with a that
Queen sitting on b7 the advanced a pawn
and knowing that the pawn hanging was
gonna be a win and later on she had some
strong gang games as well of course I
mean there's also the in-game she lost
when she made that mistake a plain
knight c6 instead of Knight c4 but
without going into specifics it was just
a really great and instructive match and
you couldn't ask for more as far as
drama goes I mean over 50% decisive
games of course that we are all human
also we have it's um it took me a lot of
time to accept that you know it's so
weird well we're making mistakes and
we're learning from them hopefully
that's the fun of it isn't it I mean I
think that's why it's so fun to be a
commentator for chess tournaments
because we appreciate how difficult it
is to play flawless chess and when it
happens it's just incredible right like
Valentina gudinas win with all those
sacrifices last year so remember the
Bishop h6 exactly so it's a it's just a
lot of fun to call the women's chess
tournament and you having so many to
experience knowing so many of these
players for so many years and especially
to have the world champion at our
tournament after such such a dramatic
victory yeah and like these tournaments
often show that there are a lot of games
which are decisive much more than in
thier example in sinky field cup so I
guess that Karin's cub will prove it
once again yeah well miss in his battle
between dr. Jeanne sings viola and Rex
Sinquefield I think Jeanne is gonna need
to offer some heavy odds because she's
always gonna get more we of course and I
think that makes him
exactly it is really it's a great
tournament and the match was wonderful
great to have the world champion with us
here and yeah I think that it shows so
many good things to come that people are
starting to raise the prize funds for
these women's just championship of
course and this tournament is becoming
traditional that's already the second
edition and I just hope that it will
serve in an example for many more so
maybe the next step would be to have
ground chest or for the women's events
so I hope that this idea you know will
will give like give a possibility to
organize well not only the Grand Prix is
but other super tournaments as well like
all over the world well one thing's for
sure woman's chest calendar is getting
more and more crowded and we are happy
to have a probably exhausted do you in
June who split her match between
Shanghai and of a lot of a stock okay
and okay you said it well I do and now
she's in st. Louis yes and we're happy
to have the world champion here